this is so ridiculous that acting like
the war room is this dark mysterious
dangerous cult the way Matt is like I
managed to get access to it welcome back
to the lay Heil pen show so as you know
vice's documentary about Andrew Tate
dropped a few days ago so I haven't
watched it yet but I'm gonna watch it
live with you guys and give you my
honest reaction just before I start the
video don't forget to hit the like
button if you enjoy it and also I'm
going to be creating a lot more of this
kind of content so make sure to hit the
Subscribe button so you don't miss any
of it some people who you've never heard
of before all of a sudden appear
everywhere
[Music]
Andrew Tate is an anglo-american
kickboxer turned influencer whose
extreme misogynist videos have helped
make him the most viral man in the world
obviously I said I haven't seen this yet
but straight away I know this is going
to be a hit piece just because
immediately they just caught a
misogynistic right at the beginning of
this before it's even started they hang
out the machete boom in her face and
grip her up by the neck but shut up
[ __ ] on December 29th he and his
brother were arrested by Romanian police
as part of
trafficking investigation The Matrix has
attacked me a few months before their
arrest I was in Romania trying to get
access to their so-called secret society
the War Room the worm is the most
powerful Network on the face of planet
today
to get inside I had agreed to endure a
professional cage fight in Romania I
know
hunger fans
be working nine-to-five jobs oh I need
to get better I need to Ebola I'm not
tough on myself nobody else will be
that's what I learned from Andrew to
take the same hole hold on to what I
found out my plan was to sew Anarchy is
that this recent arrest appears to be
just the tip of the iceberg this is
definitely a hit piece I don't care the
real story we've clearly conquered the
internet began years ago there's not a
single female complaining no no no
complaining have you seen one tell me
sweet and I guess vulnerable to being
brainwashed by education all right I'm
only one minute in and I can already
tell this is incredibly biased the way
they're using Sinister music everything
this is just a massive hit piece my
boyfriend's being radicalized by Andrew
Taylor
people don't know what he's done
oh there you go the dangerous rise of
Andrew Tate
if you haven't heard of Andrew Tate yet
it's only a matter of time before he
pops up on your news feed he's been
called the king of toxic masculinity he
has said that victims
actually
we're about to enter his compound in
Romania which was raided earlier this
year as part of the [ __ ]
investigation that led to his arrest in
2022 is that true that you sequestered
an American girl or it's not even pretty
it's girl's average she's ugly I don't
have time for this [ __ ] what about
accusation that's not true at all
hello is this Andrew Tate's house I'm
Matt hey hello just a second to have a
confirmation for Mr Tate okay cool yeah
you just let me know when when we're
allowed
okay yeah yes thank you
he looks so good hello good to see you
this place is giant yeah I can give you
a quick tour I can't show you a lot of
it a lot of it's like
off limits okay G come bite them show
them how scary you are is this the
normal level of security you have for
your house every day or is this just for
us this is the normal level of security
at my house every day I'm prepared for
all eventualities it's better to be
paranoid I kind of like cars I can tell
yeah this door leads to I can't take you
in there that's classified up on there I
can't take you in there either I feel
like I know what's in those places but
I'm not gonna say I'm pretty sure I know
what's in there you do know if you've
got to any off-limit areas like security
you're going to intercept so having my
point classified I'm basically saying
don't make the book on your face got it
TV which I never watch World title belts
I was four-time kickboxing world
champion and what's this painting over
here that's my brother who else lives
here is it just you I don't know if
you've noticed but I haven't seen any
women tied up I haven't seen any women
struggling this guy Matt seems to be you
know welcomed I live with my brother I
think you get the best version of
yourself if you live with other
competitive men I I don't have loser
friends I like sitting down with people
and discussing how we can make money
from the conflict in Ukraine that's what
I enjoy I don't want to talk about TV
interesting okay cool hi by the way
sorry to interrupt I'm Matt
Georgia good to meet you what are you up
to Georgia
working working okay that was the
weirdest interaction Matt was like
trying to check on Georgiana to see if
she was sort of like okay or if she was
held against her will it's just really
weird everybody knows if you do a little
bit of research she's worked with the
Tates for years
I don't know it like is Matt okay this
is like immediately very odd the woman
I'm trying to speak to Georgiana Nagel
would also later be arrested with Tate
in December George on the two coffees
please accused of assisting him in his
human trafficking operation
hey how's it going hi hey how are you
what are these guys up to Conquering the
world my friend through what means I run
Hustler's University which is now
currently the biggest online educational
platform in the world we've grown
extremely fast we have 110 000 students
inside of a year
this is University of the University
Hustlers University for 49 a month
Andrew Tate's online Hustlers University
promises to teach his millions of
followers the secrets of modern wealth
creation from crypto trading to drop
shipping no big deal just the biggest
online school in history is this a
Sharps order is it kind of a decorative
sword
I did a tate speech about why I have
this sword I Tate speech is like my
YouTube channel take speech yeah yeah
and I talked about how the number one
problem with the world is that not
enough men walk around their houses with
swords that's up there for sure because
if more men walked around their houses
with swords so many of the world's
issues could be fixed but you have to
extrapolate it okay for example so the
woman panicked she sees something on TV
the man comes home she's like oh you go
start wearing a master if the man walked
around with a sword
and she's like put a mask on and be like
I'm brave I don't need a mask I'm a
command I love it agreed it's just a
symbol of empowerment
you got your sword your wife starts
talking you're like
shut up
outside what I do
obviously being a comedian here and vice
of taking that seriously Vice literally
want you to believe that Andrew is
threatening women with a sword any
person with a little bit of an IQ can
tell Andrew is just being a comedian I
think it's funny cook Andrew's unashamed
misogynistic and violent views so far
seem to match his YouTube persona
so far seemed to match his YouTube
Persona show me the violence that's
happened so far everybody seems really
peaceful making money working the women
there seem really happy I don't see any
violence going on this guy is insane to
find out how he's translated those into
viral Fame I accept an invite onto the
Tate Brothers podcast emergency meeting
which is also a chance to get acquainted
with his brother Tristan
welcome to emergency meeting episode 13
we have a special guest Matt Shea who is
an internationally renowned and
respected he's a folk singer and he's
going to sing us a song Andrew's invited
his mate on our show without my consent
I'm just gonna have to bite my tongue
and listen to you guys talk most of this
emergency meeting otherwise I'm going to
walk off so Matt can you introduce
yourself telling about your singing
career tell them where you're from Etc
yeah so I'm actually not a folk singer
at all
no sorry what are you calling my brother
a liar you lie to me yes let me ask you
a question
have you ever seen the clown that hides
from gay people look at Matt smoking a
cigar
they were so nice to him have you seen
no I haven't seen yeah so you've never
seen him all right let's be nice to our
vice friends so let me be nice to him
before he does a hit piece this is
definitely a hit piece I've warned my
brother that this is a setup and this is
whatever I don't care I'm uninterested
we've clearly conquered the internet I'm
clearly Unstoppable I'm like the boar
you've invited the liberal news media to
come back they can all come just because
I'm wearing a gun I'm violent is that
how it is just God that lies all over
the table I'm a kickboxing world
champion I'm violent if you are wearing
a gun and you have knives that does make
you a little bit violent it makes no it
doesn't no it doesn't no it doesn't it's
be security aware
I won't kick Vice out of my house I
think a few more minutes no no you can
sing now or you're off the pond during
an ad break Andrew breaks character a 30
second break another five minutes in a
while
Andrew's not breaking character that's
exactly how I know Andrew when you're on
camera you're all fun and exciting maybe
you're in character and then you know
you take your headphones off on your
normal Tristan was 100 right this is a
hit piece No Doubt
get you out here you can talk to you can
talk [ __ ] back you can annoy us don't
worry no I know I'm just not very good
at a talking [ __ ]
we've had a long career we have to do um
our normal broadcast okay kick him off
the board cool man have fun guys yeah
bro this is gonna be the worst
documentary about us what they're gonna
say I don't know he has lots of cars and
money all the women love him he's sexist
oh no please don't put that on the
internet who cares whatever so true
within minutes of being on their show
the Tate content machine snaps into
action oh yeah
wow already
[Music]
I won't kick Vice out of my house
[Music]
Kate Brothers embarrass Vice reporter
maybe he didn't like how he came across
as weak in comparison to the two
brothers maybe this is like a hunchback
fighting yeah 18
000 likes
246 comments 66 reshares oh I
accidentally liked it oh accidentally
like
like people are saying
Tate win as always I'm impressed how
easily he runs over weak men's arguments
it isn't Tate posting all these videos
so who are all these people
hey brothers embarrassed Vice reporter
was posted by a fan account that has 58
000 followers and 3.9 million likes and
is just posting loads of videos every
single day right in the description this
is where it changed this Vice guy
clearly felt inadequate in comparison to
the Tates everybody watching your air
he's clearly embarrassed this is now a
hit piece right in the description of
his account says looking to level up
your life start here
it's a sign up link to the hustlers
University another account this guy is
so again a link to the Hustler's
University he's got a clever formula
here
it turns out a big part of Hustler's
University is an affiliate marketing
scheme where boys as young as 13 are
instructed to share controversial videos
of Andrew with links to the Hustler's
University underneath if so oh God
forbid young boys start to make money on
their own and don't have to actually go
to university someone signs up through
your link you get 48 of their
subscription fee 48 how generous of the
Tates by financially incentivizing 110
000 students to share his content online
Andrew has essentially built an army to
make him rich and famous in a very short
space of time excellent and he's
tactically avoiding the impact of social
media bands because it isn't Andrew
himself posting it's his Legion of fans
all I'm doing is saying that every the
[ __ ] that everyone thinks isn't allowed
to say so that's the reason I'm all big
on the internet
I'm starting to wonder whether he's just
a living me you're a loser because your
mentality is loser-ish some kind of
viral marketing campaign to Swindle
money from confused young men
[Music]
or if he really believes what he says
all I am offering is the truth
Andrew first appeared on our screens as
a reality TV star I've never been in a
situation in my life so far in my 21
years where I really want something I
didn't get it he had found an arena
where controversial personalities Thrive
I have to manipulate a lot of people to
win but something happened when Andrew
was on Big Brother one of the biggest
reality TV shows
due to events in the outside world
Andrew has had to leave the Big Brother
house he was reportedly removed from the
program when a video surfaced of him
slapping his ex-girlfriend and then
beating her with a belt which by the way
we all know was consensual did Vice say
that this is consensual let's find out
I didn't say the word list did I say
listen did I say listen no did I say it
public outrage simmered down after
Andrew released a video of his ex
claiming it was all part of a so-called
kinky game
it's just what we used to do but what
the public didn't know and what we can
now reveal is that around the time that
Andrew is playing truth or dare in the
Big Brother pool the UK police had
informed the production company that he
was under investigation for two
incidents involving other women
one of rape and a further of physical
assault
in May 2021 Tate made reference to his
arrest in an appearance on the fresh and
fit podcast I was like who are you
they're like you're under arrest for a
suspicion of assault of this dumb hoe
this is the problem this is where Tate
kind of messed up in my opinion he spoke
too much he talks way too much he uses a
lot of Hyperbole and I think he just got
himself in trouble you know he used a
lot of hyperbole to go viral there was
all these clips from fresh and fit which
is I don't know in hindsight I wonder if
you regret it it clearly didn't help the
situation that he's in
during the same period the Tate brothers
were recruiting women for a webcam
business
creating the first of their many online
courses teaching other men how to do the
same
I am her everything it doesn't matter if
I [ __ ] someone else because I'm her
everything she has nowhere else to go it
was called the Tate PhD or pimping hoe's
degree she was a [ __ ] hoe and I
spotted it instantly because she didn't
humble herself when she was supposed to
and I'm glad I didn't waste any more
time on her because she's never going to
be doing like my other girls do living
in my house letting me [ __ ] other women
remaining loyal and [ __ ] bringing me
coffees and doing as I say Andrew has
closed down the pimping hoes degree to
focus on the Hustler's University
I've said this before that I don't
support webcam businesses I don't like
women showing their bodies off for money
I'm totally against all of that however
it's not illegal and it's clearly
consensual so each to their own Luca
screen's compromised yeah so keep it
super [ __ ] vanilla but with a
historical allegation in the UK and the
Romanian police now looking into him and
I want to find out more about his
methods of recruiting women
awesome
did you at one point say that the girls
you started as your girlfriends and then
work for the webcam industry 100 of the
profit goes to you I think in a lot of
households in the world today the man is
in charge of the Investments I think
that's not an uncommon thing tell me a
view I have that you think is genuinely
insulting or destructive to society I'd
like to hear it you prefer younger women
who are 18 or 19 because you can leave
an imprint on them no when I say leave
an imprint I mean that
I understand what you're trying to say
you're trying to say that like if I get
her I can brainwash her I'm not trying
to say that if you meet a girl who's 22
and you're her second boyfriend she's
probably like a nicer person less jaded
less upset less suspicious so you like
to be in a position of power it's not
being a position of power it's about I
enjoy to show her amazing things you're
trying to attach things to the situation
which which aren't true five years ago
you said it's a terrible thing I see
nothing wrong with that everybody's
always so offended by the fact that men
prefer younger women well why does
nobody say to the 22 year old hey why do
you like men in their 30s oh are you a
gold digger then because you like a man
with money who's successful no nobody
says that at the end of the day young
women prefer older men because they're
more mature and they have experience and
that's what women like and men prefer
younger women because it's a sign of
youthfulness and fertility I guess but
when it's the women that prefer older
men nobody calls that sexist nobody has
a problem with that should bear some
responsibility for that okay so first we
agree that's a terrible thing point I'm
trying to make is the best way to
prevent yourself from is to have a
degree of personal responsibility and
not put yourself in positions as opposed
to standing there saying that shouldn't
happen because or men raise our boys
better you know what else shouldn't
happen robbery
I want the freedom to walk down the road
with a million dollars in cash is it
fair to compare the desire to walk
around with a million pounds in cash to
someone wanting to just walk around
their own city at night
well female beauty is extremely valuable
this is 100 correct so we all agree
forcing somebody is clearly a terrible
thing we all agree that goes without
saying but the world isn't perfect
there's going to be dangers around every
single corner and so everyone should
take personal responsibility that you do
have some level of accountability I will
never walk home alone at night I will
never put myself in a dangerous
situation when I was younger my dad
never let me take a cab on my own at
home why because the world is never
going to be perfect so yes as an
individual on this planet you are
responsible for the danger that you put
yourself in of course female beauty is
extremely valuable in the eyes of men
who seek to exploit it that's right I
don't give a [ __ ] having such a
beautiful woman I [ __ ] them so they
listen to me so I can get what I
actually want which is not them
it's a means to an end every single Bond
girl was exploited
that's exactly what I do
have you heard the term lover boy before
the Loverboy method yeah romantically
involving yourself with a woman and then
making money off of her in some sort of
sex adjacent industry firstly I would
call the webcam industry far closer to
psychology than sex the webcam industry
has prevented more male suicide than any
group of therapists any action group any
charity ever would right is that true
how can you measure that well it's all
about measuring it's about my personal
experience one of the concerns that
people have about that okay let me let
me correct you because I'm a
professional is that it's similar to or
people might consider that a form of
okay so I'm a professional so I have to
confirm I have to change what you just
said I have to at least con I have to at
least challenge you on it nobody's
concerned about anything that happened
10 years ago when a bunch of girls got
rich there's not a single female
complaining do you think there's not a
signal no no complaining have you seen
one tell me
Andrew says no woman has complained
about him personally he won't let us
speak to the women who work for him so
for now it's difficult to verify this
claim but I have spoken to many women
who complain about the effect Andrew's
rhetoric is having on their lives to
protect them from I've agreed not to
name them
my ex-boyfriend was radicalized by Angie
Kate to the point of certainly to
release Revenge unless I took back what
I said and on social media against his
sexist you know misogynistics it's like
a virus the things that he's spreading
the scariest thing is I have no idea if
the next guy I meet could be an Andrew
Tate man as a teacher there's definitely
worrisome there are boys who look up to
him especially those that may be
vulnerable and there's
the real world carrying those what is
wrong with looking up to Andrew Tate
tell me like I don't understand what's
wrong with that and there's silence when
it comes to people like Nicki Minaj and
cardi B everybody's happy for young
girls to look up to those characters
didn't cardi B admit publicly to robbing
men and yeah everybody's silent about
that
the boys at school my age think that
it's okay to say horrible thing like
women on men's property and they get to
do what they want with them it's really
disappointed in my generation
Andrew's views represent a new era in
modern misogyny
where you can now not only talk openly
about subjugating and objectifying women
but doing so actually Garners millions
of committed fans
believe the level
the most hardcore of them have traveled
here to Romania to join the War Room the
war room is a fraternity or a
Brotherhood which is designed to inspire
the best from our brothers they have to
have the mentality and the pedigree to
survive there's tests and if you do them
you can stay inside
at the top of Andrew's fraternity is a
small group of wealthy and powerful men
who all stand to gain significantly from
the expansion of his Empire
this Inner Circle is not happy that I'm
here yeah I wouldn't be happy that you
could test the exchange this morning
Andrew invites me to watch him train
have you ever bought before no but it
turns out he's planning on teaching me
the lesson
there you go I appear to have
unintentionally walked into a situation
where Andrew Tate is going to train me
how to box one thing
and then
pumpkin
oh none of your bleeding already we've
only warmed up keep them on bro we've
got 10 more rounds
meet and get punched in the face by the
inner circle of the War Room
in the world Andrew is creating not only
are women to be subjugated
sorry that almost felt like I got
knocked out but men defined by their
capacity to inflict violence not afflict
violence their capacity to protect those
around them when I am married my husband
better be able to protect me physically
it's a dangerous world out there I need
a man that can do that that can knock
other people out in case anybody is
nasty to me threatens me whatever it is
I need a protector this is excellent I
support everything I don't see the
problem here okay okay tap out so you
stopped you were like all right pause
time out like I thought we're having a
street fight would someone stop no no
reaction I need to fight back yeah does
that make sense yes yes this is not a
like life is not a video game that you
can turn on and off life is serious
there are dangerous things at every
corner you can't just tap out because
you're tired as a man you need to be
able to defend yourself I even think as
a woman as well we're not built like
that so that's why we need men to do
this protect our honor I think it's a
great thing the worm is a network we
have 10 meetings a year the next one's
going to be in the mountains of
Transylvania you could do it but I don't
know my friend if you're prepared
we've left Bucharest and we're driving
into the Carpathian Mountains to meet
Andrew and his inner circle for the War
Room which is going to involve something
called the test
I've made it into Andrew Tate's war room
where 100 of his biggest fans have flown
in from all across the world each paying
five thousand dollars to have their
manhood tested by the one they refer to
as Commander none of us know what he has
in store
I welcome you all to the test
there is a cage fighting event
and every single one of you has been
paired against a professional fighter
you will fight in the cage on national
television and it's a real fight there
are two paths you can go down you can
agree to fight or you can decide that
it's not for you you have one hour to
think and make a decision
that's going to be a hard no
from because he's weak maybe I'll do a
yes just to learn a little bit more of
what happens and then it's definitely
collapse at some point does anyone have
any questions to ask me
there's no training before this fight if
you've been walking through life too
lazy to [ __ ] train is that your
problem exactly
in life you don't get a call saying hey
you're going to get robbed at this time
tomorrow better get training no you have
to be ready for anything at any given
moment in order to protect yourself and
protect your family and your woman I
couldn't help overhearing some
disagreement within the War Room
we have an ambulance we have Medics
nobody [ __ ] knocked out don't worry
about it it's a very good at the center
of it all was Andrew's right-hand man
Iggy samawise
foreign
he's the self-proclaimed greatest
hypnotist in the world you will learn
the power of hypnosis and seem to have
an agenda that expanded beyond the warm
itself into something larger and darker
your sons will marry their daughters
your daughters will marry their sons you
will create legacies enjoying those
juicy Stakes that finer Scotch those
smoother cigars
he refused to speak to us but it's clear
that he has a big role to play in
whatever the war room's real agenda is
the war this is so ridiculous that
acting like the war room is this dark
mysterious dangerous cult the way Matt
is like I managed to get access to it
it's really not that hard to get access
to it but in reality it's just a group
of men coming together trying to improve
their lives trying to make more money
trying to become more masculine stronger
so they can have access to better
experiences better women I don't see the
issue here
foreign
decision time you are getting in the
cage to fight a professional fighter who
is trained to hurt you anyone who is
fighting please stand up anyone who is
not fighting you can stay seated and we
will begin the other program I support
this when I have sons one day I want
them to be strong and powerful masculine
so that they can defend themselves at
any point in time this is so important
you need to be able to defend yourself
just like that a third of the room
decides to get beaten up for Andrew Tate
what happens to people who said no
they're not getting beaten up for Andrew
take this they are ready to get into the
ring to better themselves this is all
about individual self-improvement
there's something slightly different
describing the reasons they didn't do it
how that affects their life as a whole
whether they're going to make any
changes in the future to be more ready
for opportunities that's where honor
comes from right from victory yeah one
of the men who said no agrees to speak
to us as long as we hide his face
why did you say no I have been in the
ring before but just sparring but I was
like [ __ ] professionals and Russians
like they they guys are serious I was
just too scared so then afterwards I
felt bad about myself and I was angry at
myself
because I came here to test it Andrew
Tate has already said a lot of kind of
controversial things online what do you
think about that a lot of things are
very controversial
but I think the bottom of this message
is a very very positive one because if
I'm not helpful myself nobody else will
be nobody really cares about me if I
don't care about me right that's what I
learned from Andrew trade people who
decided this morning and people who
decided that later date here we had a
chaperone following us we've been told
that we're not allowed to talk to anyone
what about in passing asking people like
what single question let me run this by
type before we film no other company
okay all right would you go for that
yeah yeah our chaperone vets who we
speak to and tries to heavily control
our questions
why did you join the war already I don't
want to be [ __ ] stagnant I need to
grow it's just a fundamental shift in my
mindset what I think could be bad is
always good you see how every man that
he's speaking to is saying the same
thing they're not doing it for Andrew
they're getting in the ring so that they
can grow they're saying things like
self-development personal accountability
learn to defend themselves these are
incredible traits that Andrew is
encouraging these men to develop and yet
all Vice can do is say no he encourages
violence not one person not one man has
used the word violence or women they've
said grow self-develop before the war
and I used to think why is this
happening to me now what is this trying
to like teach me
specifically in the things he says
online the things that get him negative
publicity what do you think about those
things
I think it's speaking the truth really
yeah
interviewing Under The Chaperone
supervision is proving restrictive yeah
no [ __ ] no Alpha craziness is a bit
of an animal on this one so we can't
speak to anyone okay
who is this mysterious chaperone anyway
hey man
good good how are you
um I was wondering if we could have a
little chat yeah
from Dubai like most warm leaders he has
a sports car do you want to do the
interview in here
oh yeah I don't see why not man and like
most people with a sports car
he's Keen to show it off this is such a
funny scene because I heard Sartorius
shooter on Twitter space is actually
giving more context to what happened so
apparently Matt actually wanted to see
the car Matt said let's do the interview
in your car and then what do we see in
the actual documentary they've flipped
it so it looks like he was trying to
show off his car the whole thing is
contrived to make hey sartora shooter
all these guys look bad it's
unbelievable and also if I was driving
that car yeah I'd want to show it off
why are they acting like having money
and amazing cause and being successful
is a bad thing so what do they call you
in these circles uh sartorial or the
sartorial shooter I'm one of the guys
who manages organizational risk and
security for the war and so anyone with
any criminal activity maybe they are
showing signs of being racist or sexist
or any of these sorts of things that out
straight away we will not tolerate them
and so how do you reconcile that with
some of the things that Andrew for
example says online any claims of
misogyny or the fact that he's you know
spreading hateful words
that's not the reality of who he is and
that's not what the worm stands for
that's not what he stands for there are
many clips of him out there saying I'm
not a misogynist I provide for my women
I would stand up for my women in a
violent situation what do you think his
detractors would say about for example
what you just said the phrase my woman
do you think that they would consider
that to be misogynist the phrase my
woman for me ties into the very
traditional values that we have on that
point there is nothing sexist or
misogynistic about saying my women it's
a beautiful thing would it be sexist if
a woman said my husband no so why is it
sexy Superman says my women if something
belongs to you you're gonna look after
it you're gonna protect it these people
are clutching at straws it's so
embarrassing to see known for talking a
lot about his multiple girlfriends how
does that tie into this idea of a
traditional relationship men at certain
levels can provide for multiple women
and even we can go back a hundred years
ago King's you know wealthy men they
would support multiple Families how is
that a bad thing it was only very
recently that men and women have been
competing in pretty much in masculine
Realms in work and career not that long
ago and indeed in many cultures around
the world women still have the
traditional gender norms and we believe
in the war and that's what leads to
happiness rather than a career or like
you have you know your own agency in the
world to pursue your own goals the women
who I know who are most fulfilled in
life
are not trying to do the things that
traditionally men used to do what about
is it women are tall and indoctrinated
to believe that a career will make them
happy they have to compete against men
basically become a man and then they hit
like mid to late 30s 40s no kids never
married miserable I even see women in
their late 20s working a bunch of jobs
and feeling like there's no purpose
what's the point and it's like of course
there's no point because you're supposed
to be having kids that's all that's
going to really make you happy and we're
trying to pretend to women that that's
not true men and women are completely
different and anybody that wants to
argue otherwise is being intellectually
dishonest situation where this is just
popped in my head where I want my
girlfriend who I love to be a capped
woman but she doesn't she wants to
pursue a career or something like that
then find a different woman very simple
or go for it if you want to be a
stay-at-home husband and she can provide
for you then like so be it do whatever
suits you but the reality is eventually
she's not going to be attracted to you
as a stay-at-home husband that's just
the reality but if you want to do it
like do it the core belief driving the
war room and what men here are seeking
is a misogynist fantasy of a time when
they were Kings and women were
subjugated it's at the heart of what
Andrew Tate is selling
just look at the tweets of Iggy
summerwise his second in command I need
to follow this guy on Twitter my webcam
girl is home 100 of the time has no time
nor interest in going out she sleeps
Cooks cleans does her shows gives me all
the money gets railed by me and our
girlfriends then Smiles thanks me and
goes and does it again tomorrow welcome
to the War Room this is the War Room
I really think you have to take stuff
like that with a pinch of salt the whole
thing is comedy in my opinion these
characters they're just online
characters Andrew acts like a comedian
the whole time they're entertainers
that's what they are so is the Iggy guy
he's an Entertainer and it's quite
possible this next story has pulse it's
not insecurity all of this is facts he
is the only person to go around on
private jet he's the only they are all
broke and this is clearly about
self-development has nothing to do with
insecurity if they were insecure they
wouldn't get in the ring this is amazing
again all they they keep using words
like growth discipline personal
responsibility accountability I think
this is really healthy actually
round
but while they come forward to
gratefully take the beatings they've
paid thousands of dollars for
little bit of blood Andrew Tate's future
on social media is hanging in the
balance
and the public backlash is spreading
I'm desperate to ask him about all of
this but first I have to get through
this ridiculous situation that I've
found myself in oh wow he's actually
getting in the ring let's go
[Applause]
fair enough I have a newfound respect
for Matt he's getting in the ring
clearly he deep down also believes in
self-improvement and development and
having something to prove to the world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
whatever's going on behind the scenes
watching me get chased around if it's a
smile on Andrew's face
[Music]
[Applause]
he just said watching him get beaten
puts a smile on Audrey's face it put a
smile on Matt's face it was all a bit of
fun he survived he's okay he lived to
clearly tell the tale this is so
contrived it's unbelievable
[Applause]
foreign
those who went all in on their fight
came out badly
one man was knocked out and taken away
on a stretcher
what happens with the Inner Circle had
put these men through Collective
hardship and recreated them in Andrew
Tate's image Fighters
he broke his hand on her if you're fine
so you win but they had also joined a
movement that was widely accused of
normalizing sexism in rape culture
well the men who'd show look how happy
they seem it's because they feel like
they've achieved something you should
challenge yourself in life you should
put yourself through as a man through
physical hardship they feel so
accomplished and so achieved and so
powerful this is so healthy those to
fight are paraded in front of the crowd
Andrew's team shame those who refused
yeah don't let it go so anyone who
fought you could put your hand up how
the experience was how it's going to
change your life and if you have
anything to say to the people who didn't
fight I don't think I have any word of
advice for the people that didn't do it
except that he should have probably
not into it right so yeah that's what I
want to do right now I have new
mountains to climb and I'd love to get
back here a year from now and go to the
channel of the guy who beat the [ __ ] out
of me didn't it feel like a movie the
last few days I feel like that's a great
metaphor for Life uh you know we
shouldn't be slaves we shouldn't be
working nine-to-five jobs we should
actually make our lives into I guess a
movie
I want to be known as one of the best
fathers in the war room I can't look at
my sons and tell them to suck it up
buttercup
if I don't say yes to this that's
incredible he just said he wants to be
the best father how can he look at his
son in the eye if he's not brave enough
to get in the ring where is the toxic
masculinity there this is so healthy
these are men thinking about their
families thinking about their children
thinking about their women and thinking
how can I be a better man how can I
defend that honor I'll get in the ring
and I'll do better I'll have goals I
will grow I don't see the issue here I
support this I love this and I hope when
Andrew has the opportunity to once he's
out of jail he can keep inspiring men to
have goals to grow to do better not one
person has said yeah now I'm stronger I
can control my women more no it's now
I'm stronger I can be a better father I
can be a better husband this should be
celebrated this is what they should
teach in schools the men here paid five
thousand dollars to the only real winner
in this performance Andrew Tate
absolutely I want to stay and relax
there's some chicks don't know where
they're from yeah let's have fun I hope
you all enjoyed it
we're told not to film The celebrations
that conclude the evening and it's not
clear exactly what goes on but once
outside the lobby we could clearly see a
room containing naked women being
photographed naked women
with Andrew's team increasingly
conscious of negative publicity tonight
could be the last chance to interview
him
do you consider the possibility that
some of the things that you've said
which have been viewed 11 billion times
may lead to an attitude towards women
that could be harmful I accept that
across all of that viewership I have
perhaps possibly maybe said one thing or
maybe two that has upset a large range
of people wouldn't it make sense to just
apologize for some of the things you've
said acknowledge that they have caused
harm and say that you won't say those
things again no and I'll tell you why
I'm not going to apologize for the edits
of other people I'm not going to
apologize for the misunderstandings of
other people there's a whole bunch of
Clips people are making which make me
look very bad that's not good for my
life that's not good for business the
clips that portray your negative light
also help the algorithm to make you
become more famous and more viral I'm
not an expert on algorithms for social
media platforms I do not have most of
them installed on my phone I cannot
control a 15 year old Singaporean
decides to do when he chops me up and
calls me names I can't control that and
I wouldn't try to there has been a lot
of bad press about you that's made some
nervousness within members of the War
and why is that well obviously when
people are going to continue to lie and
continue to do very very shallow very
very fictitious investigations people
are going to lose faith in you the media
has lost all credibility because you do
not try and portray the truth anymore
one thing and that stands in the way of
Truth for example is when we often do
documentaries we have full access to
speak to anyone we want but in this
documentary we've been very closely
watched by the Sartorius shooter at
alpha wolf picking who we can speak to
you know monitoring the interview what
is it that you're worried that we're
going to find out this question is
this is low it's low we let you in we
tried to take care of you you're sitting
here and just attacking us for three
hours bro the world is asking these
questions and the viewers will be asking
these questions it's a consistent
learning questions consistent narrative
what is the question about the good he's
doing for men well there's a very clear
narrative I need to leave
in the days afterwards Tate is banned
from YouTube tiktok this thought Torah
shoot is completely right where were the
questions about the good that he's doing
for men we literally just watched a
group of men talking about how Andrew
has just helped them become better
fathers better husbands better
protectors where are the questions about
that silence Facebook and Instagram to
the protest of his fans
they have shut us down this is Warfare
against the West
for a moment it seems the Deep
platforming has worked
but then he reappears on Instagram with
an emoji covering his face you're lost
you understand you're living inside of a
mechanism which is designed to control
moves to Dubai converts to Islam
sets up a new bank entirely owned by him
oh he sets up a bank entirely owned by
him and rebrands the Hustler's
University as the real world wow
dangerous in the first month after being
de-platformed he made 11 million dollars
and got 250 million views on Tick Tock
wow somebody was successful months later
Elon Musk reinstates his Twitter account
and he gains 1 million followers in 24
hours
have no criminal charges there's no
charges at all against me I have not
hurt any women no women are coming
forward saying Andrew hit me okay well
that was a really interesting
documentary My overall take is it was
clearly very contrived clearly a hit
piece clearly very biased I saw a lot of
really amazing opportunities for them to
talk about the good that Andrew's doing
and that was totally disregarded and I
think it's funny how this only comes out
now after Andrew's been arrested I would
have preferred a more balanced
documentary so I'll be following what's
going on but guys remember it is always
innocent until proven guilty that's
really important if you did enjoy this
video then please don't forget to hit
the like button and subscribe because I
will be keeping up to date on everything
that is going on we'll see you next week